F
ECONOMISTS RIGHT NOW THINK THE
U.S. WILL TIP INTO RECESSION.
MARK ZANDI'S CHIEF ECONOMIST AT
MOVIES, ANALYTICS, HE JOINS US
LIVE NOW.
MARK, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US.
SO, THE BIG CONCERN HERE WHEN
IT COMES TO STOCKS, STOCKS DOWN
ABOUT 800 POINTS OR SO IN TERMS
OF THE DOW.
BIG CONCERN IS REALLY WHAT
LINKS THE FEDS WILL GO TO AT
THIS POINT TO CURVE INFLATION.
>> WELL, THEY ARE GOING TO
RAISE RATES, IT'S JUST A
QUESTION OF HOW MUCH, AND ONE.
YOU KNOW, THEY MEET THIS WEEK,
MY SENSE IS THAT THEY WILL
RAISE RATES A HALF A POINT.
THAT IS WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
SIGNALING TO US FOR QUITE SOME
TIME, I THINK THEY STICK TO THE
SCRIPT, BUT AS YOU POINTED OUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF INVESTORS
OUT THERE THINKING, GIVEN, THE
REALLY UGLY INFLATION NUMBERS
THAT WE GOT LAST FRIDAY THAT
THE FED WILL BE EVEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE AND RAISE RATES BY
THREE QUARTER OF A PERCENTAGE
POINT.
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL DO THAT,
YOU KNOW, I THINK THEY HAVE GOT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND
RECESSIONS, SO THEY WON'T GET
THAT FAR.
BUT, YOU, KNOW IT'S PART OF A
STRONG STATE BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE BELIEVES
THAT INFLATION IS GONNA COME
BACK DOWN.
>> YEAH, THREE QUARTERS IS TOO
RISKY, THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE SAYING, ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE CONCERNS RIGHT NOW ABOUT A
RECESSION.
WHAT IS YOUR EXPECTATION ABOUT
THE U.S. GOING INTO RECESSION
HERE.
DO YOU ANTICIPATE A RECESSION,
AND IF SO, HOW DEEP DO YOU
THINK A POSSIBLE RECESSION
COULD BE?
>> WELL, I THINK RECESSION
RISKS ARE UNCOMFORTABLY HIGH,
OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE BEEN RISING.
I THINK PEOPLE WILL MAKE THEIR
WAY THROUGH WITHOUT ACTUALLY
SUFFERING AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN,
IT WILL FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE
TIMES, LIKE TODAY WHEN WE ARE
SEEING ALL THESE RED ON THE
STREET.
YOU KNOW, STOCK MARKETS.
BUT I THINK WE WILL NAVIGATE
OUR WAY THROUGH.
THE ECONOMY IS FUNDAMENTAL, YOU
KNOW, IT'S BALANCING HOUSEHOLD
DEBT AND CORPORATE LEVERAGE
FINANCIAL SYSTEMS.
THE STRENGTH, ALL IN PRETTY
GOOD SHAPE.
SO, I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO AVOID A RECESSION
BUT IF I AM WRONG AND WE
ACTUALLY DO GO IN THEN ALL
THOSE THINGS I JUST SAID WOULD
ARGUE FOR A MORE MILD ECONOMIC
DOWNFALL.
CERTAINLY NOTHING MORE
SIGNIFICANT THAN WE'VE
EXPERIENCE TYPICALLY.
LIKE, RECESSION 69 MONTH.
UNEMPLOYMENT RISES TO SOMETHING
LIKE FIVE AND A HALF OR 60%.
SO, I WOULD EXPECT IT WOULD GO
IN RECESSION IT WILL BE
RELATIVELY MODEST.
>> MILD AND RELATIVELY SHORT
LIVED, DO YOU THINK?
>> YES.
BUT, YOU KNOW, RECESSIONS ARE
JUST REALLY NOT GOOD, RIGHT,
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING FINANCIALLY AND A
VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY.
PARTICULARLY LOWER AND LOWER
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WHO,
YOU KNOW, DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
CASH CUSHION AND FINANCIAL
RESOURCES.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE UNDER A
LOT OF PRESSURE HERE.
WE'VE ONLY RECENTLY KIND OF
GOTTEN BACK ON THEIR FEET GIVEN
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
PANDEMIC.
SO WE REALLY DON'T WANT TO GO
INTO A RECESSION, BUT YES.
YOU KNOW, FROM A 3000 FOOT
LEVEL, IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT
FROM DOWN ON HIGH, I EXPECT A
RECESSION.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE SIX MONTHS,
NINE MONTHS, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
UNEMPLOYMENT WOULD RISE --
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
NOT GOOD, BUT, YOU KNOW, IN THE
GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS,
PROBABLY MORE TYPICAL AND
COMPARABLE TO OTHER EXPRESSIONS
IN THE PAST.
>> QUICKLY, HOW CLOSE ARE WE TO
INFLATION ACTUALLY PEAKING?
RIGHT NOW?
WHERE THERE.
WHICH MEANT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
POSSIBLE, BECAUSE THAT DEPENDS
ON OIL PRICES WHICH GO BACK
RIGHT TO THE RUSSIAN INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
WHAT GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING IN
RESPONSE TO THAT.
THIS RECENT SPIKE IN OIL PRICES
IS DUE TO THE EUROPEAN UNION'S
DECISION TO SANCTION OIL.
SO, GETTING THE TIMING RIGHT'S
WRONG BUT IT FEELS LIKE TODAY
WE ARE CLO